once you have narrative you can gain
political power I would say that AOC in
the squad are the prime uh example of
how once you gain cultural relevance
right that these women are cool and
socialism is cool then they suddenly get
elevated politically and they're on
every channel and even though AOC is
just a congresswoman from a small
District in the Bronx where not many
people voted for her actually she's
elevated into being somehow queen that
we should be listening to all the time
and what does she do when it comes to
everything well she lies and always
tells you how it's all the problem of
white people and Nazis and white
nationalists here she is this weekend
also really having to acknowledge a very
Central fact that reporting from the FBI
and from and even in terms of Homeland
Security uh Jamie and I sit and we he is
the chair and I'm the vice chair of the
house oversight subcommittee on civil
rights and civil liberties and we've
held hearings on this and the there is
absolutely no doubt out that the data
shows that the vast majority of of
incidents of domestic Terror come from
White nationalism and that we are really
truly facing an environment of fascism
and in the United States of America this
type of intimidation at the polls brings
us to Jim Crow it brings us back and and
Harkens back to a very unique form of
American apartheid that is not that long
past ago and we have never fully healed
from it and those wounds threaten to rip
right back open if we do not strongly
defend democracy in the United States of
America what do you think she says it's
what you could accuse them of awful just
awful she's talking about apartheid
she's talking about voter suppression
where are the videos lady we just played
videos last week of what's going on in
Georgia while Stacey Abrams is claiming
right now that there's voter suppression
they are having the biggest early voting
number is ever why don't you show me
some of that video of people being
intimidated so that they can't get to
the polling places right why do you
never show that lady you can't come up
with any of that AOC when you talk to
Chris Hayes before the show you didn't
say hey can you throw this video up uh
how come we didn't see any video of mobs
or of black people showing up to polling
places huge groups of black people
showing up going I want to vote I want
to vote but I don't have an ID can you
help me out we never see that either
it's so very very bizarre but what she
keeps saying is that the vast majority
of domestic Terror incidences there you
know in essence white people it's white
nationalists well my God because of the
internet we found video remember some of
this from these last couple years just
cities burning stores being looted look
at all these white nationalists white
nationalists burning down Pep Boys white
nationalists burning down Walmart look
at these white nationalists just Rampage
white nationalists got to get a TV when
I'm a white nationalist I forgot what
color I am look at this white National
yeah burning it down the white
nationalist taken out of whatever that
was there white actually burning down
apartment buildings we had two years of
mass violence in America's biggest
cities and it had nothing to do with
white nationalism okay uh it had nothing
well I was about to say it had nothing
to do with fascism except antifa which
purports itself to be an anti-fascist
movement actually is I would say the the
foot soldiers of a fascist movement
through the Democrat Party